this program is brought to you by Emory
University
oh there's so many different ethical
issues that arise in any hospital
setting but especially a grainy a lot of
ethics things follow resource-poor
situations or areas where patients just
don't have the sort of advocates it sort
of support that they need either
financially or or through family and
friends that can really make sure that
they're getting the appropriate
treatment at times and it can be
difficult so that has been a really
meaningful thing for me to be a part of
I started out as a member of ethics
committee here and I'm still doing that
and through that we do ethics consults
for teams who have complicated clinical
ethical situations that arise we help
patients in the families and we help
teams to come work together to come up
with the best situation of our patient
we also do a lot of Education to the
hospital with for nursing positions I
teach medical student ethics and now I'm
on the board at the Society for general
internal medicine Ethics Committee as
well so it's been an interesting thing
to get involved with and it also feels
really meaningful in the care of
patients
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University